we have a very interesting situation right
now where we are seeing the joining, the melding
of two major stories and one kind of explains
the other.
We have on the one hand the questions that
have lingered because Donald Trump never released
his tax returns about whether Trump is as
wealthy as he claims.
Whether Trump's businesses are as profitable
as he says they are.
Whether Donald Trump has problematic debts
to others.
And thanks not to Donald Trump, but thanks
to the blockbuster New York Times investigation,
the answers to all of those questions are
yes, yes and yes.
And in fact, there are a total of 420 million
dollars in debt that Donald Trump has, 300
million of which are loans that will come
due during Donald Trump's second term as president.
If he gets one.
So that's one story.
OK.
Talked about that yesterday.
Secondly, we have this story from July, which
I've been on top of for a while, which is
that the Trump campaign is accused of of blundering
money through its campaign laundering, donor
money and doing all sorts of sketchy and potentially
illegal things with donor money that I told
you about in July.
This is now coming together with the added
piece of Trump's former campaign manager,
Brad Parr, scale threatening to harm himself
and allegedly hitting his wife and getting
arrested in Florida.
And I'll tell you how that relates to it.
Why is Donald Trump's campaign laundering
money if they are?
Well, it seems weird to do something so risky
just for kicks.
It is explained by the taxes.
If Trump has 300 million in loans coming due
soon and 420 million in total debt and his
businesses aren't doing nearly as well as
he claims, which was also exposed by the recent
New York Times tax bombshell.
Then the reason he is laundering money could
be to free up money that was donated to him
for his campaign to pay back some of those
debts.
I mean, it's the crudest top level analysis.
The details could vary, but that would be
a very reasonable inference from what we are
seeing if whoever Trump's creditors are.
And we still don't know the full scope of
who they are, if they plan to come for Trump's
money starting in the next few years.
Then Trump urgently needs to get cash to pay
them.
And if we really want to speculate and this
is the Brad Parr scale piece, and now we're
going much further.
We told you yesterday on the bonus show that
Donald Trump's former campaign manager, Brad
Paşa scale was taken by police to a hospital
because he was threatening to harm himself.
He had barricaded himself in his home.
He had, according to his wife, 10 guns with
him.
His wife reportedly had bruises on her, et
cetera, et cetera.
Anytime someone is threatening harm to themselves
or others, we don't make fun of that.
That's serious.
But the timing of it is interesting because
based on the reports about money laundering
from July Paşa Scales, companies were major
players in laundering the money.
And at the exact time that the New York Times
story breaks, which is the beginning of the
unraveling maybe of the money laundering and
of Trump's taxes.
Brad Parr scale has a breakdown.
Are they related?
Well, we don't know.
I mean, it is speculative.
We do commentary and opinion here.
That's what we do.
The timing makes me wonder about it very,
very much.
The question in the end is how much jail time
can you end up with if you launder millions
for a sitting president?
If that is indeed what Brad Paşa scale did,
it could make even the most stable person
maybe lose their cool.
We don't know.
We'll see.
Last thing to mention here, you can tell that
they have the goods at the New York Times.
The New York Times story about Trump's taxes
likely is completely accurate because all
of the reactions are distractions.
Some Trump ists have been tweeting, you know,
it's illegal to leak someone's taxes.
Who gave it to The New York Times that concedes
that they are really Trump's taxes, right?
Or why was this published right before an
election?
That's dirty.
They're trying to influence the election.
Well, that concedes that these are Trump's
real taxes.
Right.
Or.
Who cares if Trump didn't pay taxes?
That makes him smart.
Well, that concedes that what The New York
Times is reporting is accurate.
And of course, Trump has casually said, oh,
it's all fake.
It's just fake news.
But 99 percent of the rebuttals that the right
is running with aren't substantive.
They are non sequitur.
What about ism?
The next five weeks are going to be fascinating.
We will see tonight in the first presidential
debate.
You've got to join me live for this thing.
We will see tonight at the first presidential
debate up whether the topic of Donald Trump's
taxes comes up.
We will continue covering it on our Instagram
page.
David Pakman show on Instagram.
Make sure you're following us there.
We'll be back right after this.